germany has posted a massive spike in
covet 19 cases with
more than six and a half thousand new
infections in a 24-hour period
let's have a look at how quickly new
infections have surged in the past
seven days we were at 2828 cases
last wednesday that was october the 8th
the numbers then
kept rising and there's a bit of a dip
here on the weekend when not all local
health departments report numbers
and then you see the steep rise to where
we are today at 6
638 newly registered covet
19 infections with numbers more than
doubling in one week it means the virus
is growing
exponentially and the figures come just
hours after
chancellor angela merkel met with the
leaders of germany's 16 federal
states to agree new unified measures to
slow the spread of the virus
once seen as a role model for europe
germany now fees the pandemic is getting
out of hand
though the country has fared relatively
well so far
with cases rapidly rising angela merkel
has issued a stern warning
if you ask what worries me then it is
the exponential rise
and we will stop it otherwise it will
not end well
we can see that all over the place and i
don't need to look at germany here i
only need to look in the neighboring
countries that's the point
regional leaders have agreed to shut
hospitality venues from 11 pm in areas
should they become various hotspots
a regulation already adopted by some
cities like berlin and frankfurt
counta will also be enforced in hotspots
social gatherings will be limited to 10
people from a maximum of two households
in a bid to curb the number of
infections at the political level
one bone of contention remains leaders
can't agree on domestic travel rules
that mean travelers from hotspots cannot
stay in hotels
without a recent negative test
the accommodation ban is still contested
among the states
some want to keep it up at any cost the
majority of states are skeptical
because it's relatively inefficient to
prevent infections
but in the end it causes a lot of
agitation anger and disruption
but some on the streets say it's not
more rules that are needed
the existing rules are not being
followed and they're not being enforced
all too often you see people without a
mask on buses and subways i believe the
rules should be better executed
it's a fine line when you see all the
weddings you can of course understand
but on the other hand
it's also a risk for others as well as
for the elderly
i think we all need to be reasonable
if the number of infections keep rising
angela merkel has warned
that even tougher steps may be needed
well that report by dw political
correspondent emanuel
joins us now from our parliamentary
studios emma what's behind these rising
infection numbers then
which leads obviously to more positives
as well you have to know that since
mid-august we've been seeing here more
than
uh 1 million tests being carried a week
here so
there's a backlog several laboratories
warned that they were starting to be
overwhelmed that there was that backlog
as they are reaching their testing
capacity
limit now the number of daily infections
here in germany you've said it that
reached
it reached the level of march with more
than 6
600 infections daily this is alarming
but in comparison to neighboring
countries germany still fares much
better for example
a neighboring france can account for
more than 20
000 daily infections the czech republic
yesterday counted
more than 9500
infections for a country whose
population is eight times
less than that of germany so yes the hot
spots and infection rates uh four
hundred thousand inhabitants
uh increase exponentially uh and it is
worrying but germany still has a better
handle of the pandemic than
its neighbors so far well we just heard
about the new measures that chancellor
merkel and the 16th state premise agreed
upon but
mackerel reportedly said she was not
happy with the results why
she would have wished for stricter
measures
so we've seen in the report not all
state premiers agree
for example on the accommodation ban in
various
regions so there still needs to be talks
between the state premiers and the
chancellor
regarding domestic travel so those are
all the reasons why
those negotiations took so long there
were marathon negotiations
over eight hours into late at night
yesterday and angel america had a warned
time and again that people need to keep
being careful
keep wearing masks keep respecting
social distancing
and she's reportedly also uh
quite annoyed by the fact that not
everyone
seems to be observing all the rules
so what is the plan then if germany does
not get the infection rate back under
control
well if those new measures don't suffice
then we can
very well imagine that we can see in the
future more localized
lockdowns firmer lockdowns being put
into place
the thing is that the government and the
regions want to avoid um
stricter lockdown simply because also
this would actually
be another blow to the german economy
and angela merkel actually warned that
germany
simply couldn't afford another meltdown
of its economy
dw's emanuel shah is talking to me a
little earlier
poland is also expected to announce new
restrictions after registering a
record of nearly 9 000 new cases today
the country managed to keep the number
of infections lower at the start of the
pandemic
but as dw's alexandra funarman reports
the government is now facing criticism
for failing to prepare the country for a
second wave
in the foothills of the tatra mountains
a popular tourist destination
this winter however pavo shaliga has
little hope of much business
normally his family's guest house would
welcome school classes and other
organized tour groups but most of them
have
already canceled
if we didn't own this place and just
rented it
would have already given up
no matter what
[Music]
with tourist numbers slowly rising again
over the summer pavo shaliga was hoping
for a situation to improve
but now the region has been declared a
red zone
due to a surge in covet 19 cases and
that means
additional restrictions including
wearing masks in public
spaces and a ban on cultural events
a firmer see in the center of zakopane
poland's most popular mountain resort
majina mittan abel has been running it
for 24 years
this has been going on for months now so
people have slowly started getting used
to it
but the situation for us here is
difficult
as a popular tourist destination we in
zakopane
are more at risk during the first
wave of the pandemic in the spring
poland's national conservative
government reacted quickly
by imposing a lockdown and closing the
country's borders for
foreign travelers but since then the
authorities have been facing growing
criticism for failing
to prepare poland's health system for a
second wave
we visit magena meet an abel at home her
husband originally from yorkshire in the
uk
contracted the virus in the spring
fortunately without severe symptoms
he praises poland's quick response to
the pandemic but
is worried about its hospitals the
health system in poland
is is is basically enormously lacking in
funding
and so if if the country becomes
overwhelmed
then i think it's going to be a problem
because of the number of hospital beds
the number of
respirators a little bit of medical
staff
pavo shaliga is also worried in addition
to his regular job he
organizes weddings here in the mountains
they have to be big
but it's almost impossible to plan a
wedding he and his business partners say
if the authorities make ad hoc decisions
all the time
they should have set limits from the
beginning what difference does it make
if we have 50 or 100 wedding guests
in a group of 10 people we're in a small
circle we know each other
and we can react quickly if anything
happens
what we need is a clear strategy to
combat their pandemic
pavoche liga says otherwise it will be
increasingly difficult to convince
people to comply with their restrictions
[Music]
and here are some of the other
coronavirus facts and figures from
elsewhere in the world
the world health organization warns an
additional 10 000 children per month
could die from malnutrition
due to additional economic strains
linked to the pandemic
according to a register of authorized
medicines russia
has approved a second covid19 vaccine
and the chinese city of qingdao has
fired health officials
after an outbreak of infections broken
nearly two months stretched without new
cases
city officials say they are still
working to test all nine million
residents after
this outbreak
you